make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are finishing up with the
boys we are now into the conclusion em
and in the last video that we did we
kind of did like the aftermath but you
know the the kind of big revelation that
we got right the idea that there were
essentially two two home Landers right
you had home lander as we knew him which
was the guy with the American looking
suit and all that kind of stuff then
there was black noir who was a clone of
homeland err but more powerful designed
to keep homeland ER in check or destroy
him should he ever end up you know
running a rye or something like that and
all the terrible things that homeland
her quote unquote had been doing was
actually done by black noir right he had
essentially gone gone insane more or
less and so the results of this is that
with the collapse of the superheroes the
death of homeland of the death of black
noir all these guys that basically it's
all kind of gone belly-up everybody
knows everything that's been going on
with the superhero so the stories that
were crafted in these comic books were
not real right that the reality is that
superheroes as they existed in the boys
universe were created by flawed American
and compound V and the whole idea behind
it was to secure the role of superheroes
in the defense contracts right to get
bought American all that that defense
contract money and so what we end up
doing here is basically picking up with
Voss now Voss if you guys recall him he
was part of the glorious five-year plan
which is basically Russia's superhero
team the issue here is that Voss is
literally being blown apart like
literally being blown apart there's some
guy hanging here on a chain and there's
this kind of taunting going on you
should have stayed out of this man like
you should have been involved in this
any of that stuff only for us to find
out that once he gets hit with a rocket
and basically has a hole blown in his in
his body that it was essentially Billy
butcher who was taking him out right
Billy butcher was the one who killed
Voss from there you pick up with Huey
and what you end up learning is there's
this big this big congressional inquiry
that's going on into bought American and
so that's why like when you have all
this kind of going on people are asking
questions like how far-reaching does
this go
you know like society has more or less
lost trust in bought American but
regardless of the situation what you end
up having is Huey basically heading back
and meeting with the boys - Billy
butcher right so meeting with mother's
milk and the Frenchie and the female and
basically says like we're done now the
whole point of this was to bring down
the superhero community was to
essentially bring an end to the actions
of one American and to ensure that
superheroes are more or less taken out
and funny enough the rest of them agree
you got everything going on with
Mother's Milk his daughter and his
ex-wife you got everything going on with
Frenchie and his family you've got the
female or her whole thing going on
everybody's like yeah man what kind of
down here like it's time to essentially
move on you know into more or less just
be done with it
and so at that point Billy butcher of
course shows up and then tells Huy like
it like he's not really aware of the
conversation going on with everybody
wanting to leave instead he kind of
walks in for him it's kind of business
as usual and this is hey by the way Huy
I'm gonna make you second-in-command
just like you asked and initially this
seems kind of innocuous initially just
kind of like okay so like whatever like
he was gonna be second-in-command of a
group that doesn't really have any
actual hierarchy aside from Billy
butcher leading it whatever but what
this does is it actually starts to split
the team and there's a reason why Billy
butcher did this right but essentially
it creates a rift but for the most part
when it came to Huy he wasn't really the
weakest member of the team but it was
one of these things where he it was
obvious he never really had the heart
for it he never really had the the
stomach for like killing people
torturing people things like that so he
was no really officially part of the
boys you have Mother's Milk who's been
there really since the beginning the
same thing with like the Frenchie and
and with with the female like they've
been around much longer than then Huy
has and so as a result of that Huy be
made second-in-command makes them kind
of look at him funny and if anything it
drives even more of a rift between the
team where they all kind of split off
and they all go do it you'll all end up
going in and doing their own thing sort
of leaving Billy butcher to do whatever
it is that he feels like doing at the
same time you end up having starlight
who basically bails rice she's like with
everything going on in the superheroes
the fact that everybody's hunting for us
I'm gonna go wide lo rightly I'm gonna
go lay low I'm gonna go do my thing I'll
see you when I see you and the reality
is that this was a long time coming
they've been on the rocks for a really
really really long time and there really
didn't seem to be any kind of
reconciliation that could be made there
right and so Hughie ends up going to
visit the legend and starts kind of
asking questions you know like hey man I
got this text from boss like do we know
what's going on with boss and in the
realities that nobody really knows right
boss has just kind of been in m.i.a for
quite some time now we know it's because
vos is dead and that's when the legend
comes clean that basically boss has been
killed by somebody you know they don't
really know who it is but he was
essentially kind of blown to pieces not
only that with Hughie looking at his
text message what it says is t34 at
linen basically and this is kind of like
okay so like with it being that way he
doesn't know how to make heads or tails
of it but one of the funny things is
that you end up having having legend
basically saying look if you want to get
to the bottom of what's going on you
want to like really understand what's
happening then you start making some
phone calls and explicitly you should
talk to monkey now if you guys recall
monkey was the guy who was second in
command under the director of the CIA
right he was basically her help more
and then once the director had kind of
moved on her you know from her position
and was pursuing a Senate seat that
monkey kind of became a Stewart right he
was he's like the YouTube CEO he's the
one that's running the company until
like the advertisers show up he's kind
of running the running the company or
running the CIA until like the people
who actually make the decisions come
along and then start starting you know
saying here's what we want to do here's
here's what's gonna happen right so he's
essentially a Stewart and so as a result
of that he still kind of has a lot of
control in terms of the day-to-day
operations and that's where Hugh really
kind of begins to switch right because
he calls this guy Evan says hey look man
here's what's gonna happen like you're
gonna start giving me information and
initially monkeys kind of a little big
for his britches right he's kind of like
hey man like you you don't have any
authority here you don't have any
control here the CIA disavows you all
that kind of stuff and that's when Huey
kind of shows this little glimpse of
Billy butcher right when he's like okay
well either you can do what I want what
I tell you to do or you know I can dump
all this information out there for the
world to know about what you're really
like you know about how you're totally
inept you know you're essentially
incapable of doing this job effectively
and you'd lose it before you ever really
had it so play games and you'll play
this game the way I want to play it or
you're gonna get the boot right so it's
it's pretty intense and it's very much
what Billy butcher would do and monkey
kind of being you know really in a lot
of ways a kind of coward that he is
ultimately ends up curtailing like ends
up in some sort of turn coding there now
another big thing that was going on here
is you've got mother's milk finally
catching up with his daughter initially
kind of starts to freak out or realizes
that's not really what she needs like
she just kind of needs to talk and so
the two of them really just kind of
start conversing and that's what we end
up learning that not everything is what
it seems were you look at the daughter
of Mother's Milk and you see her as this
girl who looks like she's like 18 19 20
years old the reality is she's 12 her
body just aged exceedingly fast because
of the compound be in her system that
was passed on to her by her father and
so the truth is that she still easily
manipulated and that's exactly what her
what her mother did right use this girl
to get to mother's milk and so as a
result of that initially the response of
of Mother's Milk is okay well then I'm
gonna go to i'm gonna go to wherever it
is your moms at and I'm gonna take care
of business out there only for it to be
explained that it already happened after
the team and more or less counting on
its own separate ways that Billy butcher
had traveled all the way out there and
Billy butcher had essentially gone
through he killed the ex-wife of
Mother's Milk
he killed pretty much everybody in the
room ripping their heads off or smashing
their head through a wall or something
like that but for the daughter of
mothers milk it was crushing because
with billy butcher killing her mother he
took his time right he literally grabbed
her head and just started caving her
head in in a really slow way too
she kind of felt every ounce of it but
at the same time it instilled this
insane amount of fear in mother's milk
himself and that's where things had kind
of popped off because the response was
okay he starts realizing there's
something else going on here with Billy
butcher outside of him just sort of
cutting against these various
superheroes from that point you jump
into the legend and that's when you have
Billy butcher there and what you end up
realizing is Billy butcher's tying up
loose ends
Billy butchers going from one place to
the next and taking people out now we
don't know why he took out Voss and we
don't really know why he's taking out
the legend but it seems like they're
essentially loose and characters they
have a lot of information information
that could be detrimental to whatever
the plan is that Billy butcher has going
on and so what he does is literally the
legend kind of goes fleeing for his life
only to essentially fall out and then
basically look you know up here like he
has a heart attack and then die on the
spot and that's basically it from there
Hughey ends up firing and off an email
realizing that the text message you got
from boss is t34 at Lennon dot are you
right so fires on an email says hey man
like let me know what's going on like
like talk to me you know about about
this and it essentially seems to get
like this a crazy amount of information
and it's funny because this was an
automated response that he gets right
with vas basically being dead vos had
his suspicions about Billy butcher and
so he set up an automated system that
should Huey send this email to an email
address that was sent to Huey in a text
message following the death of Voss he
would get an automated response that
would reveal everything that boss knew
right all his suspicions the whole nine
yards and that's when things start
popping off because what Huey does is
start going back and looking at
everything that took place he ends up
calling monkey talking to him he ends up
recalling his conversations with Malory
he ends up looking at all the events
that are essentially unfolded up to this
point and one of the big concerns that
Malory had was with Billy butcher going
forward and doing his whole thing the
worry was that Billy butcher was a guy
who would always need a war he would
always need a conflict he would fight
this war forever if he could get away
with it because of the vendetta and the
hatred he has against superheroes and
that was one that was what Malory
realized and then tried to cut Billy
butcher off and so what you end up
having is essentially this scenario
playing out like this that basically
Billy butcher when he came on board when
he was brought on board by Malory really
seemed that love what it was that he was
doing at the same time it was I want to
be able to take off these take out these
superheroes the vendetta that I have
against them to definitely death for my
wife you know how screwed up they are
Society the whole nine yards I'm gonna
fight them forever as long as I possibly
can and so in order to achieve this
goal that what he had done is a previous
notion was in a guy named Volvo Baum who
developed compound V was taken out that
Billy butcher didn't kill him that was
one of his first assignments was to kill
Vogel mom he didn't do that instead he
kept Vogel mom on the back burner and
Volvo bomb was the guy who had developed
the compound V that was used by the boys
in order to give them their their
enhanced abilities when you had the
whole situation unfolding for all these
superheroes were taken out by missiles
developed by the military that were
designed to essentially target them in a
specific way they could destroy them the
question was how did the government know
about this right how did the government
know this inherent weakness inside these
superheroes and the reason why is
because Billy butcher having accessed
the compound V of Mina if you guys
remember her the one who was building
that superhero army accessing that
version of compound V that could
basically be used in a way to where if
it was triggered correctly using a
correct radio wave it would blow up the
the various people's heads
Billy butchered essentially grabbed that
and then grabbed the particular neutron
in the brain and then sent to the
military and said if you develop bombs
that can access this they can track this
particular target then you'll take them
out right basically activate that that
particular substance and it'll blow
their heads apart right you guys can use
these these missiles destroy them all
effectively you know so on and so forth
Billy which was the one who orchestrated
all of that at the same time
Billy butcher had basically kept vogel
bomb on the back burner so Volvo bomb
would continue developing this compound
week even after Billy butcher had taken
all that tainted compound V from Neenah
and then attended to basically disperse
it around the world and give it to all
these various heroes or or the very
least to use it as a means to destroy
the various members of the superhero
community who were out there
Billy butcher intends on fighting this
war forever if he possibly can the Billy
butcher has kind of had this under this
this sort of ongoing a campaign that's
been taking place his entire time and
it's been trying to essentially remove
anybody who knows about it right Voss
had figured out what was going on
Voss had went to go track a guy who was
essentially just using all these trucks
and so on and so forth and moving this
compound be around Vasa track this guy
down ultimately Billy butcher realized
what boss was up to and took out both of
them the legend was taken out because
legend was the one who was gonna give
information to Hughie that would have
led him to this half anyway essentially
it was him neo nipping in the bud
anybody they could get in the way of his
plan it's actually pretty ingenious if
you think about it because what it does
is it leads to mother's milk essentially
confronting Billy butcher now it's not
as though he's confronting Billy butcher
based on this information but he
confronts Billy butcher because of the
fact that everything his daughter had
told him Billy was there Billy killed
his ex-wife
so forth and with this revelation the
billion tends to fight this fight
forever mother's most like do you really
plan on doing this is responsibily is
yes and that's where you kind of run
into the moral quagmire of the boys that
when you look at the entire superhero
community yes there are really screwed
up superheroes out there who engages
some pretty heinous activities but for
the most part most superheroes out there
just want to live their lives right they
weren't really aware of what bought
American was doing all they knew is that
they were individuals who had
superpowers and bought American was
working with him and they would give
them stories and they would say go here
and take up residence in this place a
lot of the superheroes were just good
people doing what they thought were good
things and because of that Billy butcher
doesn't really see a differentiation if
you're a hero you're a bad guy if you
have powers you're a bad guy if you
don't have powers you're probably a good
guy whatever who cares what you're doing
with the other people here is kind of
like but it's not that black and white
it's nuanced right you can't just kill
everybody with superpowers because of
some vendetta that you have this
ultimately leads to a fight between
mothers milk and Billy butcher and is
it's it's not super lengthy mothers milk
gives the upper gets the upper hand
initially but Billy butcher is able to
outmaneuver it and Billy what you're
realizing what it is that mother's milk
plan on doing ends up taking over
grenade putting it in his face and then
blowing it up right and so then it
basically blows his face apart you know
because of the fact he's still alive you
know with compound V and everything
after that suffocates him and that's the
end of mother's milk right he ends up
being killed by Billy butcher and it's
kind of nuts here right because Billy
butcher is killing his own guys Hughie
ends up talking with the Frenchman the
Frenchman basically reveals hey man
Mother's Milk spring-heeled by Billy
butcher is another one down and it's
kind of like okay so we got to keep
going after these guys right we got to
keep taking these these individual guys
out from there Hughey following these
various leads that he had picked up the
trucks that were being used to transport
the compound V that was moved by Billy
butcher in order to disperse it across
the country by basically granting people
powers and then going after them for
having powers kind of creating his own
war you know he ends up managing to
track down bo-bo-bom only to find out
that he's actually dead now
Vogl bombs serve his purpose at that
point he gets a call from billy butcher
and billy butchers is kind of like hey
man like your account of fading in and
out are you down in the lab you know all
this kind of stuff but knows exactly
where huey is and this is probably one
of the most important parts because when
the two of them are talking and the two
of them are kind of going back and forth
that you would eventually have this
instance whereby billy butcher asks huey
says hey man like how do i know where
you are and he was like well because
you're talking to me over the phone he
says no no how do I know that you're at
that house
how do I know that you're at the place
or compound V was previously stored
before I had a moved well I had Vogel
bomb creating compound V for me how do I
know that you're there and that's where
Huey begins to kind of get scared and
sort of panic and the reason why that's
important is because for the character
of Huey he's always kind of been fearful
of Billy butcher right Billy butcher
represents a kind of chaos that Huey's
not used to no one knows what Billy
butcher's gonna do and this plays out
insofar as the Frenchie and the female
in the sense that you basically have
Huey you know and the fringy talking
back and forth and it's like okay you
know that conversation ends pretty
quickly and then you have Huey basically
talking you know talking with the female
and the two of them kind of going over
there their whole thing and him really
musing over whether or not he actually
made the life of the female better the
issue is that in the middle of all this
they hear a kind of sound going off a
kind of activation and as they start
sorting through the apartment they end
up realizing there's a whole huge case
of c4 with a timer at two seconds and
that's the end of the Frenchie and the
female there the whole place is blown up
it's the end of them Billy butcher is
systematically going through and killing
off each and every member of his team
he's taken out mother's milk he's taken
out the fringy and the female and the
next person is to go after Huey because
what this does is it leads to a conflict
between Billy butcher and Huey and the
reason why is because Huey was notified
by monkey that essentially Billy butcher
had walked into the Empire State
Building and it basically said there's
gonna be a terrorist attack here
everybody has to leave right so we have
essentially evacuated the building now
he kind of has the authority to do that
because he's still somebody with some
authority in the CIA albeit not really
on a level that anybody of any
significance cares about but if you're a
couple of cops you know you're some
security guard you're some you know
Renick cops or whatever and like some
guy comes walking in you know and says
hey like NYPD here's the CIA badge
there's gonna be a terrorist attack
everybody's got to evacuate of course
they're gonna do what you tell them to
that's what they're supposed to do they
follow orders they don't really ask
questions or anything and so because of
that Huey essentially kind of comes to
this realization that it's going to end
up being a kind of one-on-one fight
between himself and Billy butcher and
it's a cool moment because Huey gets
there and immediately starts crapping
his pants right because really butcher
is kind of imposing why just one of
these things work when he speaks people
listen right he just kind of has that
commanding voice that radiates Authority
you know and so because of that you know
Huey kind of looks at that and it just
sort of terrified by this prospect right
because here's this guy that could just
overwhelm him with extreme force but at
the end of the day Huey ends up Nutting
up and gets into an initial fight with
Billy
an attorney o is obliged to one of the
window shards and the two of them go
crashing down below here we lands on one
of the spikes which how he landed in
that way is kind of strange and Billy
butcher's paralyzed from the neck down
after you know after landing the way
that he did and so as a response to that
there really isn't a great big huge
skirmish here there isn't really a great
big huge conflict the fight is is two or
three pages long and it's not even
really a fistfight and that's what's
kind of crazy about it is you would
expect this to sort of coalesce with a
great big huge conflict between Billy
butcher and Huey right this great big
huge battle all over the building and
like killing each other and in the
pillars and all that kind of stuff you
know and maybe even like thrown out of
the building and falling like 200 feet
or something along those lines whatever
the case is like you would expect it to
be this great big huge grandiose thing
but it's not
instead Huey had basically found a way
to kind of just kind of spill the beans
to ensure that the authorities would
arrive here within a certain amount of
time the other part of this was the
question about bought American right
what kind of response would want
American end up dealing with here and
that's when you basically end up
learning that when it came to you Jasper
Stillwell I think is what is what this
guy's name was I when it came to it too
you know mr. Stillwell more or less that
when he was meeting with this this
younger woman right when he was meeting
with this woman and he was having
conversations with her and the two of
them were really getting to know each
other that what this was designed to do
was essentially create a fall guy that
when he was grooming this woman and
basically saying like you know you're an
intricate member of on America now
you're gonna be overtaking my operations
of things that I was doing I'm moving
higher up in the company it was designed
to create a fall guy presenting her it
with information herb the one that kind
of carry out a lot of the campaign's
because essentially everything that had
gone on really in the last three or four
videos that we've done was really kind
of orchestrated by her in terms of the
actions of what American this guy had
basically kind of removed himself in the
equation and then turned around and
turned state's witness you know with
regards to the congressional increase
that oh my god guys because all this
information on what lot of Americans
been doing how crazy is that it was all
done by her you know and so because of
that she's the only one left hanging
right she's the one they're this face in
the firing squad and as much as it sucks
it's the smartest move this guy possibly
could have make to get himself out and
that's what's what's so significant
about this is this guy was so removed
from everybody right he didn't care
about anybody or anything just
constantly saving his own backside and
so as a result this woman kind of had to
know but at the same time she was sort
of caught up with the idea of moving
upwards in the company that she couldn't
see the forest for the trees and the
result was that she ended up getting
caught up it kind of sucks you know from
her perspective it was okay we
both making out of this with our hands
clean you know she was literally
fighting on his behalf and her behalf
only for her to be sold out you know
hung out to dry you know so it's rough
it's it kind of blows you know but I
guess I'm gonna work in the corporate
scene maybe that's what it's like out
there I have no clue if it is I don't
want to be a part of that scene I though
that's a little more than I can handle
right like I'm not in the business
leaving folks out to dry
nonetheless you know with Billy butcher
basically you know being stuck back here
on Empire State Building completely
paralyzed from the neck down you know
he's gonna be caught by the cops he's
gonna be thrown in prison and that's
gonna be the end of him and so in order
to kind of go to Huey the thing that
he's realized that Huey would always
sort of engage in a violent action if
he's pushed in the right direction and
if he's led to believe that there's a
justification for it Billy butcher comes
out and says I murdered your foster
family like I killed everybody back home
and Huey just immediately flies into a
rage and the reason why is because
that's just kind of what he wanted right
like Huey wanted to kill Billy butcher
anyway and Billy what sure knew it but
he just couldn't really bring himself to
do it because he's never been able to
write he's never been the guy who could
just look at someone and say you're a
toll ton to die and that's it right I
mean he's never really been able to do
that right and so because of that and
Billy butcher kind of pushed him in that
direction because he alternative for
Billy is to spend his life in prison
paralyzed from the neck down a shadow of
his former self you know and so with
Huey killing Billy butcher he in turn
calls up his family only to realize
they're alive and well that everything's
fine they've the last laugh of Billy
butcher was to manipulate Huey into
sparing Billy the worst fate right with
him kind of going to prison which is
what Huey planned on the he didn't want
to be controlled by Billy butcher
anymore he didn't want even if you led
by him anymore at the end of the day the
final joke is but like you still were
and you did that in order to kill me
because I got you to do it right so
again that's what the story ends it's
kind of it's kind of nuts there is an
epilogue and we can probably because we
can cover the epilogue at a future date
whether it is an epilogue to it which is
kind of cool but yeah like it's
interesting right like it's it's kind of
cool well it's a pretty cool story the
boys is is is certainly interesting
insofar as taking traditional superhero
themes and twisting them on their head
but again that kind of goes into the
fact that Garth Ennis is like super like
super cynical more or less but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end for the future
uncensored videos I don't think I'm
gonna put any of those on YouTube I mean
we did the boys I think the other ones
we're gonna leave off YouTube public
instead we're gonna leave them on
patreon strictly for the patreon
uncensored patrons they're gonna kind of
see all that stuff they can see all the
answers or videos which is basically
everybody just like a
a month where you see like all the
uncensored videos the next one that
we're gonna do well I guess I'll
announce that one on patreon so do you
guys want to see it go head over to
patreon comments explain but I'll
announce it over there the next one
we're gonna do and hopefully you guys
will dig it right I'm gonna let you guys
vote on it to be honest like I might let
you guys vote on the uncensored comics
which once we do make the poll available
for like two or three days so you can do
your research see which one you like the
most but uh yeah guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you guys are new
here to come and explain make sure you
hit the sub button to become part of the
Rob core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace I want to say
thank you to all of the new patrons who
have joined patreon.com slash comics
explain I want to give a shout out to
Henry young - Elias G David J s Jakob H
Ben John H Jason see Austin s Austin H
James O kristymatt in Jeff are Joey M
Steven Z sloth-like Lou David see John H
lean and mean that guy asked questions
all the time Adam Cajun gnosis 9/16 I
want to say thank you to all of you all
this list is growing all the time
thank for joining the patreon
[Music]
you